I know that's going to be brigh days
[Music]
Christian
and all of you guys online as too as
well we're glad for y'all to be here I
want you to know that you are not only
welcomed here but you are celebrated
here with
us all right guess what today is
Father's day and I'd like to say a
little bit of Praise over our
fathers let us pray praise those who
have fathered us in their role as
mentors and guides Let Us Praise those
who are about to become fathers may they
openly Delight in their children Let Us
Praise those who need our
forgiveness and Let Us Praise those who
have died but live in our memory and Let
Us Praise those who continue to nurture
us and speaking of delighting in our
children I'd like to welcome Anna up to
talk to us about
[Music]
summerama hey everyone and fathers happy
Father Day Father's Day we are so happy
that y'all are here what Su Summit how
are
you um so just really quick I want to
remind all of our parents that we have
samama this week on Friday and Saturday
so if your kiddos are are not signed up
yet please please please use this QR
code that's up behind me and sign them
up it is such a fun time this year we
are doing Olympic themed so it is going
to be a lot of fun games and activities
um and you have a lot of volunteers that
are really ready to work with your
kiddos um if you have any questions you
can find me after service or anyone who
is wearing this lovely kids t-shirt um
and we will have all the answers if you
need a kid to vouch for how much fun it
is there's a bunch of them in the front
row that'll tell you all about summerama
and in this front row as well and they
never shy away from their opinion so um
you are wanted even if you are an adult
we would love to have you as a
volunteer um and we just cannot wait to
have sumama this summer so thanks guys
thank
youna all
right well now it is uh time for us to
settle into
worship uh it comes to a time now for us
to release the
busyness to quiet the noise and to
settle our minds and our hearts and our
bodies as we cross the
threshold into the kingdom of Silence
Stillness and
simplicity a sacred
space a space of prayer and worship and
adoration a space to behold
Christ the revelation of God the
heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to wash over you to find you to
mend your
heart and may we all come home
[Music]
thank you johnine and Anna would you
guys go ahead and stand with us and
we're going to sing some songs
[Music]
together and as a quick note I know our
kids normally head out to kids ministry
right after this first song but kiddos
if you could stay put after this first
song we want you all to be present with
us while we do our child dedications
tonight and we will dismiss you right
after that so just hang tight all right
we're going to sing called me higher if
you know the song please sing along and
if you don't you can just let those
words settle in over your heart as we
[Music]
worship I could just
say I could just sit and wait for all
your goodness and hope to feel your
presence I could just
stay I could just stay right where I am
and hope to feel you hope to feel
something
again I could hold on I could hold
on I could hold on to who I am and never
let go Ang me from the
inside I could
be I could be safe here in your arms
never
leave let these walls down but you have
called me higher you have called me
deeper and I'll go where you will lead
me
Lord you have called
higher you have called me deeper and
I'll go where you will me Lord You Lead
[Music]
Me You Lead
Me I can hold
on I can hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the
inside I could be
sa I could be safe here in your arms and
never leave home never let these walls
down you hold me higher you have me
deeper I'll go where you will me
[Music]
me you have called me higher you have
called me deeper I'll go where you will
leave me Lord you lead
[Music]
me
you're and I will be yours all I will be
yours through all my
life let's sing that
together I will be
[Music]
I will be yours for all
my I will be
yours I will be yours my life so let
your
[Music]
mercy I will be
yours I will be your through all my life
so let your mercy like the
me you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will me
Lord you have called me higher you have
me deeper and I'll go where you will
lead me Lord
oh you have Hold Me Higher you have
called me deeper and I'll where you will
me you have called me higher you have me
deeper I go where
you me Lord
[Music]
You're oh
all right y'all can be seated for a
moment and if you are a parent or
Guardian uh and you're part of the child
dedication you can come forward in a few
minutes I'll invite like you know the
rest of the family and other people to
come join you for prayer but for now
just the parents and uh and the kidos
are part of this this
ceremony and kind of spread on y'all
come over come close don't be shy Come
Close yeah right there is
great sorry I SP you had little too
much well uh thank you all for being a
part of this and uh this is a really
this is a special special moment um I
think we all know how difficult it is to
uh raise children I think that's sort of
always been true in history but right
now it's a moment you know in in this
kind of day and age and time and um
people I think feel so stretched and
kind of stretch thin that uh it's I
think it's really important that people
feel loved and supported uh and so part
of that is as a church Community some
what we're doing tonight is this is kind
of twofold purpose one it's a chance for
these parents and um Guardians
to kind of basically commit to love this
child or children to uh raise them in
the way of Jesus and um Express to them
the God who is love uh so much of our
image of God is shaped by parents in
very close core relationships so this is
partly it's it's a chance for those um
adults to kind of make that commitment
um to the the kiddos it's also though a
chance for us as a community to kind of
make our own commitment and obviously we
have a different relational Dynamic it's
not like we're all parents you know it's
not quite that but it is us as a
community making a commitment to these
little ones to as often as we see them
to love them to support them and also
commitment to um these parents and
Guardians to say hey we're here for you
we have your back and so in a in a
moment we'll um read a liturgy that
there'll be some a chance for parents to
respond and also towards the end um for
us as as a community to uh to respond to
that so um let's go ahead and we can put
up that that
liturgy
and there are we might need to I don't
know if we can zo we might need to zoom
in all of the all the kids are like like
I can read it we're like yeah well
um so how about we'll do this I can I
can read it I just turned 40 but I can
read it with context so um you can see
the parts in red it's um the first few
portions are the parent Guardian to say
I believe um I commit and I will and I
will do my best um so those are kind of
the responses and then at the very end
you can see it says Church
um at the very bottom for those who
can't read it in the response there is
we will so um let me go ahead and and
read this and then parents you can kind
of respond in the appropriate
place so I believe this child is a gift
from God and I Endeavor to express this
truth in my actions and in my
words yeah y'all say I believe good and
I commit to surround this child with an
atmosphere of unconditional love and to
guide them toward the ways of Jesus and
the fruit of the Holy
[Music]
Spirit I will be present and engaged
even when the journey is rough I will
pray for and with my child when we are
struggling or when we are celebrating I
commit to listen when I would rather
yell to speak the truth when it is
uncomfortable and to be patient when I
am tired I will look for the good work
God is doing in my child and call it
Forward I
will I will do my best to be a living
example of Christ's transforming
love and parent from the values I see
lived in the
gospel I will do my
best I realize parenting can be
challenging and I acknowledge my need to
support and encourage and to have
support and encouragement from my church
Community I acknowledge my
need now church do you commit to love
and care for these children will you
listen to them encourage them and
patiently bear with them as they
discover who they are in
Christ we will in the name of the Father
the Son and the Holy Spirit
amen um but we're going to have some
time now is is for um some folks to pray
over them so if you um have been asked
to to say a prayer uh the band's going
to play and we'll have some just some
time for prayer um I encourage all of
you to also take this time though to you
maybe it's just extending your hand out
or just saying a Praying a blessing over
these you know families and uh to kind
of participate you know in this uh in
this moment so uh we'll take some time
to do that and then uh I'm going to
close this out with a prayer also if
you're like extended family or you know
you're here for this ceremony feel free
to to come forward and participate um in
this in this time with your with your
family so
[Music]
yes
this Pro
creation bless
[Music]
feel the function really as a whole un
Nations what a blessing they are in the
name of Jesus
[Music]
it's
gracious God Giver of all
life we pray for these parents and
Guardians give them wisdom and patience
let your peace en Joy dwell in their
homes instruct them in your truth
strengthen them in faith sustain them
through prayer order their lives by love
we pray for these
children be gracious to
them draw them to yourself help them to
love and Trust Christ we pray that you
will grow them in faith that they all
might mature and represent you well to
the world
and finally I pray over this community
may we be a strong and stable context of
love and belonging for each of these
children in the loving and Powerful name
of Jesus I pray amen amen
[Music]
[Applause]
all right our kids are dismissed to
their classes now your teachers are
waiting over there at the doors for
you thank you Katie and
[Music]
Maggie then you guys are welcome to
stand back up we're going to sing just a
couple more songs before our message
Gary's going to lead us so you guys can
just
[Music]
follow you are my
joy you are my
song You Are The
World the one I'm drawing from you are
my
refuge my whole life long away where
else would I
go God is strength of My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me then when I feel that I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me yeah
[Music]
day after
day night after
night I will
remember you're with me in this fight
allthough the battle de AG is on the
world already
won I know the world already
W to be my gu
to My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me and when I feel like I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me surely my God is strength
Through My
Soul Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me and when and I feel like I'm
all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends me We Sing
Hallelujah you're my
portion my
salvation
huah show be my God is strength through
my soul oh your love defends Me Your
Love defends me and when I feel life I'm
all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends
me God is the F of My
Soul Your Love
defends your love
is and when I see I'm all
alone Your Love defends Me Your Love
defends
me sing Hal
Hallelujah you're my PO my
salvation
Hallelujah you're my portion my
Hallelujah you're my
portion my
[Music]
salvation Psalm 69 says save me oh God
for the waters have come up to my neck I
sink in the myy depths where there's no
foothold I've come into the deep Waters
and the floods engulf me I'm worn out
calling for help my throat is parched my
eyes fail looking for my
God but I pray to you oh
Lord in your great love oh God answer me
with sure salvation rescue me from the
Meer don't let me
sink deliver me from these deep
Waters peace
[Music]
please bring it all the peace the storm
surrounding me let it
break at your
name still
I call the sea to
St the waves in me to St every
r at your
name Jesus
Jesus you make the darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus you silence
fear Jesus
Jesus you make the Darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus bre I call these bones to
lay and call these lungs to sing on
again I will
Praise Jesus
Jesus you make the
darkness Jesus Jesus
silence
fear Jesus
Jesus you make the darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus again Jesus
Jesus you make the darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus you silence fear
Jesus you make the darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus sing your name your name is light
that the Shadows can't
deny your name cannot be
overcome your name is
alive forever lifted
High your name cannot be
overcome we sing Jesus
Jesus you the darkness transform Jesus
Jesus you silence
Fe Jesus
Jes you make the darkness tremble Jesus
[Music]
cuz your name is a light that the
Shadows can't
deny your name cannot be overcome
your name is
alive forever lifted High your name
cannot be
overcome that again your name is
alive forever lifted High your name
cannot be
overcome your name is mine forever
lifted High your name and love be
over we sing Jesus
Jesus you make the darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus you silence
me Jesus
Jesus you make the darkness TR Jesus
Jesus
[Music]
Jesus you make the darkness tremble
Jesus
Jesus you silence fear
Jesus you make the darkness trouble
Jesus
[Music]
Jesus God thank you that you can quiet
the
rage and the
waves and the chaos of our souls
[Music]
that you can flood your light into our
dark
[Music]
darkness that your presence brings hope
and life and
peace God would you settle our waves
would you still our storms
would you hold us in the palm of your
[Music]
hand you are a good
God full of love and
compassion full of light and tonight we
look to you
God speak to our hearts lead
us and we will follow after you
in Jesus
name
amen you guys can greet the people
standing around you and then be seated
and Brett will start us on our message
well Grace and peace it is uh so good to
be with you my name is Brett pronounce
he him and uh yeah it's just it's a joy
a joy to to gather here to be with you
all and uh that includes those join us
online love you all Lots you're not
forgotten and um anyone here tonight who
is new thank you for for being Among Us
it it your presence means a lot I not I
know a number of you are here for the
child dedications to um support them and
uh and then also just sometimes you know
folks are visiting and I know it can
take a lot of courage to come through
those doors especially depending on
Church backgrounds and stories and
histories and there can just be a lot of
feelings a lot of a lot of feelings you
know you see the the cross and the
everything you just kind of come through
you know and it's just like oh man um so
I I hope you you feel a sense of welcome
and um love here in this in this space
so um we are in the midst of a series
right now uh titled holy shift a 21st
century faith and uh we are kind of
taking a fairly critical look at culture
um I think it's easy in our kind of
world to get this like weird split going
where we have like you know the sacred
and the secular the the kind of the
spiritual and the mundane life or
something and we and we can kind of even
operate in that way in our own life and
world you know it's sort of like okay
well Sundays Sundays are for God or you
or at least the church service that's
for God and then I kind of go back to
life and you know there I have to just
sort of operate and and uh this series
is really about taking a fairly hard
look at culture and some practices to
say like well how does our faith and you
know everything we're talking about
following Jesus and you know these songs
and such like how how how does this
actually start to touch down what does
it impact what what difference does it
make so we've looked like last week um
was on like
consumerism the practice of of kind of
never being satisfied just always
wanting more more more more more uh the
title of the message this week is Holy
shift hustle
culture uh anyone familiar with hustle
culture few of you yeah if you were on
the social medias you might be familiar
with hustle culture uh so for those
unfamiliar this refers to a a movement
of uh kind of hyper
achieving and uh and kind of chasing
sort of striving for like success uh
especially in the kind of
entrepreneurial World though it can be
just sort of in general kind of
corporate life um in general and uh it
kind of emerged from Silicon Valley in
like probably the I don't know early 90s
maybe or maybe late '90s early 2000s and
is it's now really kind of popularized
and perpetuated mainly through social
media uh whereas we'll get into people
tend to talk about it quite a bit and if
you're familiar with the INR you can
think of it as like threes gone wild
sort of like that's kind of just if
you're not fam with the Ingram it's like
that's like the Achievers you know the
achiever like I will win and this is
like that on steroids you know it's just
like yes the the winning you want to be
a winner well then great you know hustle
so you might Rec recognize it by its uh
some of its hashtags I I like looking
for some of these rise and
grind so great uh hustle harder hustle
never stops sleep is for
losers here's a few quotes from hustle
culture Advocates I guess you'd call
them um we'll start with the oh man well
I've got two quotes for you one from
Grant Cardone
this guy oh the next one's from Gary vuk
he has some Humanity I appreciate some
things about him but Grant is just all
just punchable so he says this um most
people work 9
to5 I work
95 if you ever want to be a millionaire
you need to stop doing the 9 to-5 and
start doing
95 so that's the you could tell just
punchable you know just kind of like
okay I roll um or here's Gary bchuk he
says this on a daily basis I'm scrutin
izing my 12 to 15 hour days down to the
second and trying to fill in as much
stuff with the smartest stuff into that
bucket so that's just micro speed I
genuinely believe that 95 to 98% of the
people reading this Have It reversed
they're not squeezing every second out
of every day uh
I I followed Gary ve as he's known
online for a few years and um you know I
like I mentioned he has kind of a human
side that I do appreciate in a way that
a lot of folks uh in this world don't um
but still I've followed him now for you
know I I quit probably two two years ago
I just couldn't take anymore but um you
know having read probably hundreds of
his tweets and seen I don't know how
many videos and you know I have a good
feel for where he's coming from and he
had this thing he put out for a while
called The Daily V it was basically a
recap of his day so like he just cuz he
had a camera crew like falling around
all day you know so they would like
literally follow every day and then at
night I guess they would edit it and
then at like 7:00 a.m. the next morning
they're putting it out you know like so
it was like a daily documentary of his
life so because of this though you did
get like a behind the scenes look and he
I mean everything is said in that quote
he really is he is trying his best to
live it I mean he's working from like
6:00 a.m. to 11:00 p.m. uh it is just
meeting meeting meeting meeting in
between he he works at of New York so he
hires someone you know to drive him so
because he doesn't have time to drive
between meetings cuz he's on his phone
and I mean it is constant like in
between meetings he's just churning out
as he calls it content that's kind of
the term just sort of hate content you
know just content just tweets and
podcasts and he just boom and everything
is
is I mean they got and there is
something kind of frenetic and frantic
kind of about him um that it is just
this kind of I don't know it's sort of a
uh it's I don't know if it's anxiety
it's just this energy you know it's sort
of like man
are you abusing at or all you know that
question I'm just like gez this is a lot
going on here you know I mean that's
kind of the the vibe of uh of this kind
of movement and I think what happens is
that people um maybe particularly young
people though though not not exclusively
uh kind of see this and um geted to it
you know they get attracted to it they
they they I think it's it's sometimes
it's that longing for Success you know
you know um but they get attracted to
this life that really is it's pretty
much predicated on I'd say competition
and comparison you know it thrives on
comparison uh this this sense of um you
know why rise and grind why asleep for
losers well because the whole point
right the whole end game is to to not be
a loser you know it's to be what to be a
winner and uh this is why social media
figures so prominently in the movement
because in ways it's often not enough to
just kind of quietly live this you know
no where's the pleasure in it like it's
just a bunch of work if it's just that
no the pleasure in it is talking about
it you know what I mean it's posting
about it it's like I'm I'm hustling
harder you know it's and there's that's
kind of the where the I think energy um
comes comes from right it's this whole
idea of hey you know look at me world
like look at how hard I'm working I go
to the gym and I'm going to read a
hundred books this year and I come in
earlier and I stay later and I work
faster I'm better that's kind of the the
vibe it's just I'm I'm better those
people out there they're weak you know
but I am strong and and I am valuable
because of this this is sort of now the
unspoken subtext I am valuable I I am
worthy now I'm worthy of love and
admiration you can kind of hear the the
the subtext of the movement you know
it's it's this need for validation which
is often why it's so public as well
right because it's it's not just like I
just love what I
do it's not that simple you know what I
mean it's look at me look look at at
me and uh I I think this is the danger
right the danger of hustle culture
culture ultimately is that it's it
becomes this idolatry of kind of the
optimized
beautified perfected self it's this um
it's kind of a it's it's quite
narcissistic honestly um and there's a
lot of self self-obsession going on and
which also means by the way it's quite
empty quite empty which is the reason
I'm bringing it up here and kind of
naming it for us because I don't want us
to kind of fall into this this trap so
to speak because because it's empty it
it leads to this um this sense of
unhappiness and so so it's not about I'm
not don't hear me saying like you know
don't you dare work hard that's bad you
know it's like oh no there's a place for
hard work of
course but it's this whole um this
competition this
comparison that kind of eats us up in
short I think it's kind of the the
problem of H hustle culture is the it's
really it's the spirit the vibe of it
it's that that Spirit predicated on
competition and comparison and never
good enough and never satisfied it's
really what the what the Bible calls The
Way of the World um but I'm here to name
tonight thanks be to God there is a
better
way there's just a flat out better way
to live than right and Grind from I
don't know 6:00 a.m. to midnight and
um I I was kind of reflecting like
what's the opposite of hustle culture
what would that what would that be and I
don't think it's like laziness you know
I don't no I don't think it's that I I
think if if hustle culture is this kind
of restless competitive um
comparative kind of go go go go go fast
fast fast fast fast more more more more
more this kind of anxious striving then
I think actually the opposite of hustle
culture is inner
peace just a sense of
peace and maybe I work a lot of hours
today or maybe I work not a lot of hours
today it's not so much what it's
about it's
about this like are are are we okay
here and here
in short a Christian response to hustle
culture is a life marked by peace and
contentment towards the end of his time
in this material body on Earth Jesus
summarized what he was leaving us in
this way I want you to pay close
attention to this verse it's short but
it's really insightful this is John
14:27 he says
peace I leave with
you peace like just imagine all of the
things he could
leave and you know it's not even a good
work ethic I leave with you I really
hope yall run those churches well you
know
no peace I leave with you my peace I
give you I do not give to you as the
world gives which we'll come back to
later um do not let your hearts be
troubled do not be afraid and when I
think of kind of hustle culture at its
worst at least maybe at its best it's
like you know working hard but at its
worst I think of a troubled a troubled
heart a Restless there it's it's
characterized by that frenetic Restless
quality a troubled heart and
mind in in a way it's like almost this
way of being that's getting nowhere
faster and faster all the time but when
I think of Christ when I think of the
spiritual path I just think of a person
of a life marked by that peace you see
peace is how I know I am an alignment
with the spirit of Jesus
Christ peace which is kind of an
interesting question at any moment in
your day you can just kind of just tune
in and ask yourself how at peace am
I like right now how at peace am
I that like that's when you
know you're tuned in to Christ that's
when you know you're connected to God
it's it's that sense of deep and abiding
peace and of course the reverse is also
true I I can I just can tune in it for
myself I'll just kind of pick on myself
I know know when I'm in that kind of
restless crazy anxious mode I'm just
like going and I'm too I'm just stressed
out I got no time for people and their
problems you know wasn't not good for a
pastor you know uh that's a good bad
mode you know um because it's it's the
opposite of Peace where just whatever
I'm going through it's going to be okay
you know maybe it's not perfect I'm not
saying you know you have peace because
all of your external circumstances align
and well you know you're going to be
waiting a while if that's what you're
waiting for now this is a different
different kind of Peace it's as the
scriptures say a peace that passes all
understanding see when we are young we
might foolishly wish that Jesus in John
14:27 said 1 million dollar I leave you
all Earthly power I give unto you
you but those uh those are
nothing compared to the Peace of
Christ I'm just imagining if we hadn't
you know already sent a lot of the
kiddos out and my boys if they were
sitting here they'd be like whatever
like I just know they're like they were
think Dad no a million dollars is the
answer you know that's the all the but
that's the thing you grow up and like
you maybe hit a certain income Mark or a
goal or you know I mean a thing
and if you have peace along with that
thing well then cool you know good for
you hit a goal but without
peace you're like I'd trade anything you
know like take me back to what I was
making out of college if can have that
peace that Abundant Life may have heard
the uh the story that's kind of it's
made the rounds in the last few decades
all over the Internet of the uh the
American Investment Banker who was at
the the pier of a small Spanish Coastal
fishing Village and uh he saw a boat
pull up with just just one fisherman and
he had you know a whole kind of catch
there and some several large yellow fin
tuna and the American uh complimented
you know the fisherman on the quality of
his fish and he asked hey how uh how
long did it take you to catch those and
the man replied oh only a little
while the uh American respond he said
well why uh why didn't you stay out
longer and you know catch more and the
man explained uh well I I have enough to
support my family and our needs so you
know it was enough and the American
asked well but but what do you do with
the rest of your
time and the Spanish fisherman said well
I sleep late I fish a little play with
my children take a siesta with my wife
Maria stroll into the village each each
evening where I sip wine and play guitar
with my friends I have have a very busy
and full
life the American scoffed well I have a
Harvard NBA and I can help you you
should spend more time fishing and with
a proceeds buy a bigger boat with a
proceeds from the bigger boat what could
you do you could buy several boats
eventually you'd have a whole Fleet of
fishing boats now instead of selling you
could your catch to a middleman now you
could sell directly to the processor
eventually opening your own canery you
would control the product the processing
and distribution of course you need to
leave the small fishing Village for
Mexico City eventually you have to make
your way to La then New
York the fisherman then asked yeah but
how long would all this take 15 to 20
years the American said what then asked
the fisherman the American laughed and
said well that's the best part when the
time is right you would announce an IPO
you'd sell your company's stock to the
public and become incredibly Rich you
would make
millions millions the fisherman said and
then what the Americans said well then
you would
retire you would move to a small
coastal fishing village where you would
sleep late you'd fish a little you'd
play with your kids you take cestas with
your wife Maria you'd stroll to the
village in the evenings sip wine and
play guitar are with your
friends you see if you have the Peace of
Christ if you have the peace that passes
all
understanding
friends you're already
winning like that that is winning that
that is and that that's what I think so
much of hustle culture misses it's
striving for this aim you know this goal
this endpoint this IPO or you know
whatever for life to really begin you
know like then it's going to start then
I'll have happiness
and instead of realizing like you know
what why not just begin
today and why not start living today why
not tune in to the Peace of Christ today
and allow the future to be what it will
you know you want to go for business
success don't hear this message as kind
of anti-t trying or you know having
dreams or no sure go for the dreams or
do the thing you know go for it but do
it man make every step as you do it a
step of
peace and you know the best part is
um it's really it's a piece that cannot
be taken away you know this is something
that's tricky about hustle culture is so
much of it's so fragile you know it's so
dependent on others and like certain
things going well you know as long as
the customer like your product or as
long as your boss you know acknowledges
your things you've added or you know as
long as things line then you know you
could really get somewhere and maybe
this could work and don't get sick you
know or whatever like there's kind of
this whole it's sort of predicated on I
really hope things align here um but
you'll notice what what Jesus said there
again in verse 27 peace I leave with you
my peace I give to you I do not give to
you as the world
gives because how does the world give
it's like the world gives with one hand
and takes away with the other you know
it's like you you get it and then it's
taken away or you you have it for a
little while and then it's it's gone
just like that whereas the peace that
Christ gives oh it it lasts it sustains
it's it's a it's because because it's at
the level of the Soul it's deep in our
mind it's it's a deep transfiguring work
within us that that cannot be stolen or
taken
away so this is the shift that I think
we need it's it's from hustle culture
from a life of hurry and worry and
endless productivity to a life marked by
peace and
contentment in the name of the Father
the Son and the holy spirit
amen so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
in the in the wine maybe you found
yourself maybe not fully immersed in
Hustle culture but boy if uh you're an
American culture or Western culture you
are to some degree touched by this and
so maybe you come in here tonight a
little bit just
exhausted um
feeling like I said earlier stretched
too thin may this be a moment um as you
come forward to connect with Christ
where you recover yourself you recover
your soul and a sense of Peace of
Christ so the way we're going to partake
in communion uh tonight is we're just
going to go kind of row by row so we'll
just start at the front and we'll work
our way back we just form one line right
here and um we practice what's called an
open table so if um you know whoever
would like to partake you're you're
welcome to to do that uh regardless of
exact theology or denomination or you
know whatever having said that if you're
in a place where you'd rather not
partake that's okay too you know no
judgment you're um free to do that or
not you should know the red is wine the
white is grape juice and then finally um
you can just partake whenever you'd like
some people take immediately some folks
like to come and kneel here at the front
some just return to their seats and uh
and partake there so this is the
table not of the church but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come you who have much faith and
you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here
long you who have tried to
follow and you who have failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
he
we're going to close with a song called
Slow Me Down um many of you have heard
us do this one before you welcome to
stand and sing this along with us or if
you'd like to sit and reflect on the
words that's completely fine as well um
but let's just invite Christ to speak to
us to slow our thoughts to um for us to
listen to what he has for us as we go
into this next week and and try to leave
some of our hustle behind
[Music]
oh good shepher would you teach me how
to
rest I'm rushing o will you make me to
lie
down will you build a fold by the water
that
refresh will you call my name and Lead
Me safely
[Music]
out from my anxious drive to labor On
and
On from the Restless grind that has put
my mind to sleep
will you call me back and gently Slow Me
Down Will you show me now what to lose
and what to
keep oh good
she oh
great Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh
shepher oh great
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
[Music]
Down When my tables bent with only breed
and gold
when my grasping hands are afraid you
won
provide Will you pour the wine that
loosens up my
hope say your table here with what truly
satisfies oh good
she oh
great so Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down oh good
shepher oh good
friend Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down on the busy streets trying to make
myself a
name the work is yours I nothing I can
CL will you leave me home to the
pastures of your
peace if the house is yours I'm sitting
at your
feet oh good
shepher oh
good Slow Me Down
SL me
down oh the
shepherd oh
the Slow Me
Down Slow Me
Down
Slow Me Down
[Music]
well thank you all for joining us this
evening um if you're new to the table
you can scan the QR code and fill out an
online um information card or you can
fill one out at the table on the way out
the door uh this is just so that we can
follow up with you answer any questions
questions that you might have and say
thank you for visiting my name is
johnine and I'd like to let you know
that if you're in need of prayer someone
to talk to or just a hug that I'd like
to be here for you so look for me after
the
service generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship so again
all that information is available at
that QR code or you can go out to the
website at the table tx.org
now if you are interested in the Safety
and Security of our
congregation and of this worship time
and space then there's a meeting after
the service today that we'd like to
invite you to
attend and now if you'd like to
stand or you can just open your
hearts um you can hold your hand hands
out in a posture of receiving I would
like to send you off into your week with
this
blessing you are a child of
God you you are a child of God and this
is true on your best day and it's true
on your worst
day so as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and
lows
and everything in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are loved that you are worthy
and that you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone that you come in contact
be blessed and we'll see you next Sunday
[Music]